while the world mourns the loss of a
prince tonight the las vegas community
honors the life of a hip-hop king
dmx passed away on friday after
suffering from a heart attack a week
earlier
tonight new era las vegas is holding a
vigil to celebrate one of rap's most
iconic voices madison kimbrough joins us
live from mlk and cary with more
madison yeah sasha the vigil is taking
place in front of the mlk statue that
you can see
right behind me it's meant to bring the
community together to honor an artist
that meant so much to so many
especially within the black community
people have started to gather in a meet
and greet setting where the rapper's
music will be played later on
followed by a ceremony later on where
those who want to speak
will share the impact the rapper had on
their lives flowers candles and prayer
will follow
dmx began his wrapping career in the
early 1990's
and released his debut album 23 years
ago that was in 1998
however throughout the years he had a
long struggle with drug addiction and
legal battles
that took center stage the host of the
event minister stretch
sander of new era las vegas shares his
thoughts on the artist's life and legacy
and what he means to him we can't grab a
musician we can't grab a leader and find
a perfect human being
right there's always going to be
something people can say well he was
this
he was that i think the dmx had a pure
heart i think that he meant well
a lot of the music of today has been
commercialized and so the music doesn't
speak to the conditions
well dmx was the last of that tribe he
was the last of those mohigans
who music they recorded music that
reflected the community
the rapper's family released a statement
where they said dmx whose birth name was
earl simmons
was a warrior who fought till the very
end he loved his family with all of his
heart and they cherished the times they
have spent with him
later on we hope to talk to more people
about what dmx meant to them
we got some people here even from
michigan that came all the way over to
las vegas
to celebrate his life we also hope to
show you more of the ceremony as it
takes place until seven o'clock
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now